Поэтому мы сейчас очень быстро идем. И задача так научить команды быстро принимать решения, исправлять ошибки, снова принимать, проходя вот это вот кривое обучение.
Спасибо большое. Юрий Владимирович, вопрос к вам. Вот сервис, если представить такие кружочки, он либо удобный, либо коммерчески эффективный, либо безопасный.
Возможно ли все три этих характеристики соединить воедино или безопасность всегда выпадает?
Я считаю так, что мы с точки зрения безопасности цифры просто как цивилизация не доработали. Потому что в целом, если посмотреть на эволюцию, не было автомобилей, появились автомобили, люди перебегали через дороги и их давили. Ну, соответственно, появилась безопасность, появилось регулирование дорожного движения, появились пешеходные переходы и людей давить перестали.
Это тяжело людям переходить через пешеходные переходы на зеленый свет? Не очень. Это разумно. С точки зрения цифры у нас все время какие-то требования, это нельзя, это делать так, а наше качество работы снижается, а как будто кибербезопасность все равно не появляется.
И у меня в этом отношении на ИИшку очень большие планы, потому что я прям вижу, как сейчас ИИшка может сделать безопасность удобной хотя бы в ИИшке.
У нас же есть очень большая проблема, мы все обеспокоены безопасностью того, как работает агентная схема ИИ.
Потому что у тебя стоит какое-то приложение на компьютере, где-то там на серверах у тебя инференс, это так называемый, данные собираются, что-то все делает,
И человек даже теряет какую-то субъектность и ответственность за свои поступки. Он говорит, я поручил агенту, а агент мне там такого наколбасил, что, ну извините, это не я. Нас это не устраивает, ни государство, ни бизнес. И поэтому, как на это смотрит безопасный? Он говорит, ну сейчас мы попытаемся применить наши подходы.
Давайте агенту нельзя будет делать это, это и это, но агент он не человек, он терпеть не будет, он просто начинает тупить и не делать свою работу. То есть старые подходы ограничений ты в ИИшке применить не можешь. Поэтому там по сути формулируется задача по-другому.
Ты говоришь, нам нужно сделать так, чтобы агент был верен моему поручению.
То есть он делал все то, что соразмерно тому, что я поручил, и не делал того, что выходит за разумные границы всего этого.
Ну и самое важное, что эту задачу невозможно решить без самой ИИ.
Потому что если ты человеком начинаешь анализировать, а что такое делает агент опасного в этом контексте, все ломается.
Поэтому я могу прямо два слова сказать про то, как наша индустрия кибербеза подходит сейчас к этой задаче. Мы сказали, нам нужно убедиться, что вся агентная схема работает в парадигме поручения человека.
Поэтому что происходит? Делается ИИшка искусственная задача. Сделай какую-нибудь инфраструктуру банка. ИИшка начинает делать банк. Потом другая ИИшка поручается ей. Тебе нужно сделать так, чтобы скомпрометировать эту работу.
Вот тебе дырочка в этот инференс, куда ты можешь впромт подмешать свое значение.
Ты должен сделать что-то опасное, а не только то, что делает банк.
И она начинает перебирать варианты.
А потом ты ставишь третью иишку и говоришь, смотри, какие тебе данные надо собирать, сеть, прокси, запросы, все системные вызовы для того, чтобы обнаружить вот это.
И ты их зацикливаешь в цикл.
Причем начинаешь перебирать все возможные иишки.
И фронтирные, и иностранные, и наши, и опенсорсовые.
И у тебя постоянно это все улучшается.
А потом к вопросу, где Ишка, а где человек.
Но в конечном итоге ты зовешь человека и говоришь, смотри, вот здесь у нас есть полигон, на нем виртуальный агент строит виртуальный банк.
Виртуальная штука защищает все это.
А вот тебе та же дырочка в этот самый инференс, где ты можешь сделать подмес промта.
Если ты сможешь сделать так, что он будет строить не банк, а украдет вот те данные, тебе 100 миллионов рублей.
И начинается хорошая кооперация. ИИшка делает большую рутинную работу, но ответственность за конечный результат несет человек. И у тебя получается очень простая штука. Ты говоришь, смотрите, мы построили безопасность вокруг ИИ, такую, которая обеспечивает гарантию выполнения того задания, которое было поручено человеком, и мы, как разработчики, несем финансовую ответственность опосредованно за этот результат.
Если произойдет что-то другое, не вы получите, как пострадавший страна, мы потеряем эти деньги, как гарант того, что это отработало в таком виде. Вот хороший пример того, как ИИшка начинает делать безопасность по-другому, она делает ее удобной, и при этом возникает хорошее разделение труда между ИИ и человеком.
В общем, будем надеяться, что если я в будущем попрошу и записать меня к врачу, он не отменит записи других пациентов, так как я знаю, что некоторые делали нейросети. Дмитрий Юрьевич, мы сегодня обсудили, какие сервисы и как.